welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition and you're now
locked into the channel where we've been
watching The Watchmen to break down
everything that you need to know about
the new season on HBO throughout this
video we'll be recapping episode six and
discussing where the show could be
heading in the future there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the latest entry
yet and don't want to know what happens
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of
Watchmen episode 6
okay so episode 6 picks up immediately
after the huge cliffhanger at the end of
episode 5 that saw Angela downing her
grandfather's pills faster than my last
recap got down boated for saying that
they were hers thanks for sticking with
me everyone I'm sorry for being an
absolute mr. Phillips I guess I'll have
to be him as well as nor he or z-man
Deus makes an appearance in this episode
and instead this entry focuses heavily
on the Past most notably the revelation
that will was in fact hoodie justice
though we've never had concrete answers
before over who had a justice really was
many speculated that the character was
strong man Ralph Miller and this even
carried over slightly to the show with
the show within a show hinting at him to
be the fictional man this was always
thought to be the case in the fandom as
in 1955 hooded justice disappeared which
Hollis Mason chalked up to him not
wanting to be unmasked due to changes in
the law
Hollis himself thought it was Muller and
a year later mother's body washed up on
the shore of Boston with a bullet in the
back of his head this cemented for many
that the characters were one in the same
but now we finally know the truth though
it's probably not what Alan Moore would
have wanted but what would he have
wanted in my opinion it's a brilliant
changeup for justice as he's always been
one of the most enigmatic characters in
Watchmen so I really enjoyed learning
his backstory this episode is heavily
centered around the past and most
notably inheritance and how one's
actions can echo throughout their family
forever being passed on from generation
to generation I've always been someone
who thought that though we may not ever
know our ancestors in some ways we do
because they influence the people around
them most notably their children who
to influence us and our personalities in
some way echo their actions angela is
definitely an example of this and the to
bear quite a lot of similarities the
sixth entry opens with the Watchmen logo
being changed to the Minutemen who were
original versions of the Watchmen made
up of members like the original Nite Owl
Silk Spectre silhouette comedian dollar
bill captain metropolis and hooded
justice we open with the fictional
hoodie Justice sat in an interrogation
room on the American hero story TV show
that cements that the public have a
fascination with the character that
still exists today hoodie justice and
masks in the room and it's clear that
the public or at least showrunners
believed him to be a white man it's an
awesome way to open the episode and
shows just how much the past has been
whitewashed all black and white washed
as we get into the real meat of the
hour-long entry angela is on a nostalgia
trip and Laurie needs her permission to
have her stomach pumped wills mother
faithfully plays the piano and is soon
like Careless Whisper last time becomes
a motif of the episode with the
character appearing in almost impossible
places such as fields and sidewalks I
took this as meaning that no matter
where we are the past still plays a big
part and this episode feels like a trip
down memory lane from me off Angela
takes the role of her grandfather will
Reeves who has just graduated as a
police cadet in the New York City office
will is the only black man in the class
and this systemic racism is still very
much prevalent within the ceremony even
though Reeves rightfully ranked with the
rest of the group the white officer
ignores him and instead it's real-life
police officer Sam battle who places
wills badge on him Sam battle was New
York's first black policeman and the
legendary figure warns will to beware of
the Cyclops in the audience watching
over will is his wife and the future
mother of his child and we later learn
that she was the child that he carried
down the road after the Tulsa massacre
in the first episode now the choice to
set the episode in black and white is
quite inspired especially with the
racial undertones during the time life
back then very much was black and white
with segregation and separation of races
enforced on a lot of levels and the lack
of color backs of the dichotomy that
existed in society during the time will
is said to be very angry and it's clear
that the past still looms large
over him with the character being unable
to escape the events of Tulsa much in
the same way that Angela cannot escape
the nostalgia trip that she now finds
herself on will oversees a man that we
lay alone is called Fred throwing a
Molotov through a Jewish owned business
and he takes him in for questioning
fred is openly racist at the police
department and though it seems like the
white officers have Will's back not long
after fred is back on the streets
mocking the character for his lack of
authority during the exchange one of the
officers loops his fingers and puts it
on his head making a circle which is of
course a symbol of the Cyclops that
battle warned him about this is a big
aesthetic in the episode with will
coming to the realization that just
because you wear a badge it doesn't mean
that you have power corruption and
Prejudice is rampant throughout the
force at this time and it's one of the
main things that forces him to take up
the role of her justice and to become a
vigilante he ends up seeing the severity
of just how bad this is firsthand later
on but the acorn that grows into the oak
tree is definitely planted here Action
Comics issue one is seen in the episode
as well and this clearly heavily
inspires the character to become a
quote-unquote superhero now what I love
about this episode is the transitions
between the time periods the sets are
massively cut together so that things
often come off is one shot and to me it
had touches of the video game the evil
within a doubt Lindelof ever played that
but the transitions between locations
times and so on in that or as masterful
as they are here it's all tightly knit
together and it beautifully keeps up the
pace will is walking home and the same
group of officers ask him to come for a
beer which will turns down as the car
pulls off we see dead bodies from the
Tulsa massacre being pulled behind it
showing that Will has trouble letting go
of the past for him the past is the
present as it is for Angela right now
going through this journey will is
beaten badly and taken out to a tree
similar to the one that Jed was hanging
from and the noose goes around his neck
as well as a mask which as we know would
become a big aesthetic of the vigilante
hood of justice
the officers let will go with the
warning but it's clear that this has
stuck with the character which he
beautifully portrayed in Angela Kings
raspy performance now I have seen people
criticize Watchmen for being too woke
but this kind of stuff did really happen
and the Tulsa massacre was a real abend
so yeah with them going this route
it's probably the best way to handle it
will walks home mask and noose around
his neck and sees a couple being
assaulted which is when he dons his
costume and runs face-first into the
group badly beaten them here hooded
justice is born and the character has
taken the symbols of oppression that
have so long causes race anger and
repurposed them into a hallmark of
righteousness now personally I think
this entire thing is a brilliant way to
take the already established law and
reinvent it with a new meaning how did
justice was always a kind of met
character to me but this gives him
purpose and the reasons to do the things
that he did while it's also allowing it
to tie in with real-world events to
comments on how Hollywood whitewashes
things with its depiction in American
heroes story which I've just realized
might be a play on American Horror Story
being how the world remembers the
character Will's wife asks why he wore
the hood and he becomes clear that will
doesn't believe that you can get real
justice with a badge which is when June
says that the only way that this will
ever be legal is if the public believes
that the man under the mask is white
June paints around his eyes white which
is kind of a parody to me on how
typically in Batman films they paint
around his eyes and black and the to
confirm that as will cannot trust in the
law he must now make his own form of
Justice we see the grocery robbery store
scene from another angle the one in
which it really happened and we learn
the true motives behind it with it no
longer just being a cool action scene
here will his track down Cyclops members
who were part of the KKK and he beats
them bloody and discovers a book on
mesmerism this plays massively into the
overarching story of Watchmen and hints
that the cavalry are planning to
hypnotize black people into turning on
one another which is showcased later in
the episode we discovered that this is
Fred's grocery store which explains why
he was burning a Jewish one and also
evaded the long arm of the law so easily
it's a nice reclassification of a scene
that we've already witnessed and we see
Laurie once more reaching out to Angela
to attempt to call her home Total Recall
her home yeah yes still suck Cal is
present and he attempts to get here to
remember her life rather than becoming
stuck in Wills Cal talks her through her
childhood and there's lip service paid
to the fact that she was born in Saigon
and that they met in Vietnam now for
those who don't know in Watchmen history
one the Vietnam War and it became a
territory of the country this is why the
Watchmen American flag differs from the
one that we know and it also explains
why both the characters would randomly
be there anyway Nelson Gardner comes to
me will one day believing him to be
someone that is supplying hooded justice
with information Gardner is in fact
captain metropolis and he wishes to
recruit her to justice as he is the hero
that inspired the minute men's creation
there's the subtext of their romantic
relationship here with the talk of true
companionship a hand touch and how
though he is welcome in the group others
on as tolerant as he is this reminds us
that racism exists in all facets of
society even though seeking justice and
metropolis suggests that it keeps his
mask on at all times
even though the group would be thrilled
to be fighting alongside him will in
Gardner begin a relationship and June
reveals that she is pregnant we
flash-forward hooded justice joining of
the Minutemen in which his true fears
are silenced in favor of promoting
ridiculously titled mob bosses and a
racist advert for a bank we then jump
through the airs watching wills child
grow before going to the Capitol Theater
during a screening of The Secret Life of
Walter Mitty and which an attack is
broken out here we learn that lorna who
initiated the attack saw a flicker in
her head which made her lash out at
those around her this links back to the
mesmerism book and we discovered that
the KKK aka Cyclops have been using
projectors to cause riots if you don't
have epilepsy then congratulations this
scene will give you it because god damn
will tries to get Gordon's help but he
mocks the idea that there's a conspiracy
going on and says that black people
should handle black people problems
becomes clear that Gardner doesn't value
his opinion and instead just views him
as an object saying that he has to sort
the problem out on his own but that he
can come over whenever he wants
will is confronted by Fred who doesn't
recognize him and we learn that it is
his warehouse that is producing the
mesmerism projectors will kills Fred and
then every Cyclops member including his
fellow officers and burns the location
to the ground will returns home and
discovers his San Marcos painting his
face white to become a new hair
adjusters and as I said earlier he
recognizes the inheritance that he is
leaving his son and though he doesn't
want Marcus to pick this up as we know
it's difficult to shake the mindset and
influence of our family tune ends there
marriage and takes Marcus to Tulsa and
we cut to the present to see well using
the mesmerism device on Captain Judd
which hypnotized him into hanging
himself we finally have an answer as to
how this was done and in all honesty
it's a twist that I didn't see coming
I always thought that wil was lying
about killing Judd to get Angela to
investigate the murder further and and
at the truth but this explains how he
was able to carry it out will clearly
knew about the KKK members in the police
force from his youth and has likely
followed these all the way to captain
Judd and the seventh Cavalry George says
that the Klan robe is his legacy and was
his grandfather's and again there is
this motif of inheritance and how we
carry on the lineage of our ancestors I
don't know how we'll manage to get
memories of this in pill form that
quickly but hey it's TV and we end the
episode with Angela getting bombarded by
the memories that made him which wake
her up in lady throughs for varium as we
know will is present there and Angela
now knows the truth about him going
forward it looks like we will be getting
Angela's life in Tulsa as a child and
how June shaped her to become the person
that she did
much in the same way that she shaped
well to become her to justice lady to
divulges that she has a plan to save
humanity that starts in Oklahoma and
personally I think that the 7th cavalry
may be using the mesmerism technique to
get black people to turn on one another
in the area they will be using the
teleportation device to cover this up as
an alien attack and true plans to
reverse this and as she sees it save the
world though it could be another
diabolical plan in the same vein as
Ozymandias speaking of Ozymandias it
looks like he is being put on trial and
personally I believe that he will be
found guilty and as a punishment for
breaking his agreement will be sent back
to earth which is what we saw crashing
in the field in the lady true centric
episode personally I believe that upon
arriving as he was encased in gold and
this was the statue that we saw in Lady
truce with Ariel whoever's going on I
can't wait to see as this show just
keeps getting better and better and
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this episode and if you agree with
the theories in this video comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed it
then please give it a thumbs up and
don't forget to check out our breakdown
of the series so far which goes over all
of the things you missed and our
thoughts on when the show could be
heading last week I dropped a video on
lady true discussing all the theories
behind
and what's going on so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
the true identity of the character we
also do a podcast called watching The
Watchmen in which you break down every
issue of the Watchmen page by page and
also give our thoughts on Doomsday Clock
I leave that linked at the end and if
you want to come chat to me after the
video then make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey weld over
to my discord server which you'd be
linked in the description below those
are the best ways to keep up to date
with all the latest videos on the
channel so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the marble phase 3 part 2
boxer on blu-ray which contains Black
Panther infinity war endgame Captain
wobble or more and all you have to do to
be in with a chance of winning is like
the video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on Watchmen in the comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen on the 15th
of December and the set will be shipped
out from the end whoever gets the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you